Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Comedy-Podcast-Projekt Das Podcast-Ufo. Gleich erwartet dich ein einzigartiger Dialog zwischen dem begabten Autor und Schachtitan Käpt'n Stefan Tietze und dem gefragten Schauspieler und Podcast-Veteran, Verhörspezialist Florentin Will. Ich wünsche dir viel Vergnügen mit der aktuellen Episode. Hallo, ihr hört das Podcast-UFO. Wir haben 16.16 Uhr in Formel sitzt Florentin Will. Mein Name ist Stefan Tietze und jetzt hört... Hallo Stefan, herzlich willkommen auch da alle draußen im Sektor. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Wir haben eine ganz vollgepackte Sendung für euch heute zusammengestellt, da bleibt kein Auge trocken, müdes
Fuck! Kein Gerstenkorb, kannst du es nicht, du kannst es nicht!
Hey, wir sind die lustige Morningshow, wir können jetzt nicht...
Fuck man, ich hätte heute nicht zur Sendung kommen können.
Dreck Scheisse, fuck!
Ich war halt schon den ganzen Tag Scheisse drauf und ich wollte mich eigentlich krankschreiben, jetzt sitze ich hier, komm, okay, jetzt lass uns machen, was haben wir, Adele?
Alles klar, nee, wir hören jetzt erstmal Somebody to Love von Queen und wir sind gleich wieder zurück. Du kannst das nicht on air machen, du kannst nicht on air so Ausbrüche haben. Du hast fuck fuck fuck scheiße fuck fuck geschrieben. Ja, sorry, es tut mir echt leid, aber ich kann so nicht mehr... Uns hören Kinder im Sektor. Warum hören uns Kinder im Sektor? Ich dachte, es gibt kaum noch, hatten wir nicht den Bericht, dass es kaum noch Kinder im Sektor gibt? Wo hört der Sektor auf? Es gab den Bericht, aber inzwischen gibt es wieder Kinder im Sektor. Wo kommen die Kinder im Sektor her? Weil jetzt klingt, als wären wir in so einer Last of Us-artigen Dystopie. Der letzte Sektor. Alles, was bleibt, ist der 1Live Sektor. Ist der 1Live Sektor? Bei der grossen Zombie-Apokalypse, alles, was bleibt, ist nur noch ... Ja, kurz für die Leute, die nicht aus NRW stammen. 1Live, einer der grössten ... Schade. Schade, sorry, tut mir leid. Geilstes Bundesland. Viel Spaß ausserhalb des Sektors. Unser Jugendradio 1Live sagt immer, statt NRW haben die diese eine ... Es gibt eine Regel bei 1Live, nämlich, du kannst, man kann sagen, was man will, alle können fluchen und es gibt gar keine Gesetze, der wilde Westen, aber immer statt NRW muss gesagt werden, der Sektor. Ja. Und ich weiss nicht, woher das kommt. Es ist auf eine Art genial, weil es so catchy ist, aber mir ist gerade zum ersten Mal klar geworden, dass so District-9-Vibes natürlich auch versprüht. Ja, total. So wahnsinnige Endzeitstimmen. Und vor allem, man muss natürlich auch... Ein neuer Virus im Sektor. Man muss natürlich ganz verfassungskonform auch sagen, das ist kein hoheitlich abgesteckter Bereich. Das ist eher eine Idee. Elsass-Lothringen gehört zum Sektor. Nein, stopp. Doch. Nein, das haben wir in mehreren Weltkriegen geklärt. Das Thema ist langsam durch. Nein, nein, geklärt haben, ist BRD, NRW, was wir nicht geklärt haben. Warum müssen Sie jeden Elternabend damit anfangen, dass Sie noch mal diskutieren wollen über Elsass Lothring? Ich sage, es ist schön da, das Essen ist fantastisch, Elsässer Flammkuchen finde ich ganz lecker. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich setze mal kurz meinen Aluhut ab, okay? Wir wollten eigentlich heute über den neuen Speiseplan für die Kinder reden, aber ... Okay, nur noch einmal, weil das passt ja auch dazu, weil Flammkuchen habe ich jetzt nicht gesehen auf dem Speiseplan. Ist sehr viel vegan. Machen Sie ... Das über Elternabenden die Rebellen ... Sorry, Entschuldigung, ich dachte, das Thema betrifft mich nicht. Ich dachte, das Thema betrifft mich nicht, deswegen habe ich kurz meinen Laptop aufgemacht. Doch, es betrifft sie. Wir haben doch schon letzte Woche geklärt, dass sie nicht die militärischen Mittel haben, das Elstas Lothring zu erobern. Wenn die ganze Schule mitmacht, wenn wir alle gemeinsam in den Skikeller gehen und uns die Stöcke nehmen, vielleicht. Die gepolsterten? Nee, die Skistöcke. Ach so. Und dann vielleicht in der Sporthalle irgendwie die Medizinbälle oder so, oder die Völkerbälle. Und dann spielen, können auch Völkerball spielen, und wer gewinnt, kriegt Elsass-Lothring. Okay, ich schreib's mal auf die Agenda. Ich glaube, Medizinbälle sind das Schlechteste, was du in einem Kampf haben willst. Wieso? Es ist einfach furchtbar, unhandlich. Das Tolle an Medizinballen ist, sie sind gleichermaßen schwer, trotzdem ungefährlich. Sie sind wahnsinnig, sie sind das Worst of Horst Words. Sie sind schwer zu handhaben und richten kaum Schaden an. Die Vorstellung, einen Medizinball ins Gesicht zu kriegen, stelle ich mir. Herr Petrassen, Sie haben sich jetzt festgelegt, dass der Medizinball die schlechteste Waffe ist. Ja, in der Tat, wir haben verschiedene Waffen getestet und es ist rausgekommen, dass sie damit am wenigsten Schaden anrichten. Weswegen historisch bedingt der Medizinball militärhistorisch keine Rolle spielt, ganz im Gegensatz zum Karabiner, der mit einer enormen Wucht Bleigeschosse herüberschleudern kann aus grosser Distanz. Okay, sehr gut. Mir gefällt auch, wie Sie langsam diesen lästigen Akzent abgeworfen haben. Wie eine Eidechse im Krieg. Ich muss ein bisschen reinkommen und langsam, aber dann, wenn man warm geredet ist, dann kann man das alles so ein bisschen abwerfen. Du hast halt abgeworfen wie eine Eidechse den Schwanz, um Feinde zu verwirren. Genau. Ja. Und klappt das wirklich bei Eidechsen, habe ich mich mal gefragt. Ich glaube, die Verwirrung ist vergleichsweise hoch, wenn du denkst, so, das schnapp ich mir jetzt. Und plötzlich denkst du, moin, das waren zwei die ganze Zeit, auf wen muss ich mich konzentrieren? Nee, ist es nicht eher, dass man den was, weil die Katze zum Beispiel, Katze trifft auf kleinen Barthagam, da geht es der Katze ja wahrscheinlich nicht um einen Riesen-Meal, sondern die will wahrscheinlich einfach nur, wenn die den Schwanz abwirft und dann wegläuft, dann hat sie was zum Snacken. Weißt du, was ich meine? Ich verstehe schon, ja. Ich weiß es nicht. Ist es zu verwirren oder ist es um denen etwas zu geben? Ich dachte immer so, das ist deren Konstruktionsfehler, dass die weglaufen, aber das Folgetier ihnen dann immer in den Schwanz beißt. Und man irgendwann mal gesagt hat, wir haben diese eine Schwäche, dieses lange Ding, das wir eigentlich nicht brauchen. Aber sagt's, Leute, sagt's nicht weiter, sagt's nicht weiter. Sorry, ich habe gerade glaube ich, ähm, nein. Ich bin die Claudia, ich habe mich bisher noch nicht vorgemerkt. Ich glaube, ich habe eine leichte Panikattacke oder sowas. Alles klar. Atme durch. Wenn es zu schwer wird, kannst du verschiedene Körperteile abwerfen, um deinen Kreislauf zu kontrollieren. Also brauchen wir auch noch andere Sachen nicht. Ja, wirf den Hut ab. Also brauchen wir noch ... Wirf die Hand ab. Den Hut ab. Aber die Grenze bei Eidechsen zwischen Körperteil und Kleidungsstück ist natürlich verschwommen ein bisschen, ne? Weil wenn du natürlich anfangen kannst, Körperteile abzuwerfen nach Belieben, Larifari, sagen wir jetzt einfach mal, dann... Das ist eine Echsenart. Ja, genau. Wann ist es dann Körperteil und ein Kleidungsstück? Ja, wie Exoskelett ein bisschen, ne? Ja. So wearables. Ich frag's mich wirklich. Und vor allem wenn ... Also du gefällst mir, wenn man sich so ein Germany's Next Topmodel-artiges Format jetzt mal vorstellte. In einem Idexen-Setting. Okay, ja. Ich glaub, haben wir alle schon mal gehabt. Und dann sagt jemand, ne, du bist für mich eine klare Zehn von zehn, außer dein Schw Schwanz gefällt mir nicht, dann kannst du natürlich auch abwerfen,
in der Hoffnung, ein besserer wächst nach.
Ah, okay. Aber dann musst du sozusagen, angenommen,
du hast einen Fünfer-Schwanz, und dann sagst du ...
Dein Schwanz ist eine Fünf von zehn.
Ich re-roll, könnte es aber einen Dreierschwanz kriegen.
Oder du kriegst einen Siebener-Schwanz.
Aber wie viele Rolls gibt's? Wie viele Rolls hab ich als Eidextin?
Einen pro Monat. Einen pro Monat?
Ja, aber wenn du auf einem Siebener bist, denkst du, halt ich den?
Wie bei Poker, halt ich den oder versuch ich es noch besser zu machen?
Vielen Dank. Das habe ich als Eidechse. Einen pro Monat. Einen pro Monat? Ja, aber wenn du auf dem Siebener bist, denkst du, halte ich den, wie bei Poker, halte ich den oder versuche ich es noch besser zu machen, gebe ich noch Karten ab? Stimmt, das ist Poker. Das ist für mich Poker, das zählt für mich zu den wichtigsten Dingen beim Poker. Und dann natürlich, wenn ein Siebener, vielleicht passt der auch besser einfach, es ist nur ein Siebener Schwanz, aber der passt halt gut zu mir. Ja, ja, ja. Auch merkwür, wenn alle nur mir auf den Schwanz starren. Das Wort ist jetzt natürlich missbräuchlich. Naja, also ich sag mal so, angenommen, es gäbe jetzt so eine Art Feedback-Kasten der Evolution, wo jedes Tier hingehen kann und anonym, das ist wichtig, anonym einen Feedback-Zettel abwerfen. Ich glaube, ich weiß, was von wem kommt. Der kürzere Hals. Aber du hast deine Hand. Ich weiss, glaube ich, von wem der kommt. Ich habe zu wenig Beine, ich habe zu viele Beine. Gut, das kann man zuordnen. Ich habe zu viele Beine und zu viel Hals. Ja, Giraffen, wir wissen, dass es von euch kommt. Ich könnte auf 998 Beine verzichten. Okay, tausend Füßler. Thank you. Wir sind wie der Wattelehrer, der dann doch noch alle Noten laut vorliest. Wir lesen diesen Feedback-Kasten, machen wir auf und blamen alle. Ja, und sagen, warum die Unrecht haben. Was meinst du, welches Tier würde sich am meisten beschweren? Bei welchem Tier würde die Schlange aufhalten? Also das Tier, die Schlange, die auch noch was einwerfen will. Ich bin zu lang.
Puh, also es gibt ein paar Tiere, die haben es glaube ich gar nicht gut getroffen.
Wie zum Beispiel, also weil
ich sag mal so, die Gadget-Tiere sind mal jetzt
raus. Sowas wie
Chamäleon kann Farbe ändern.
Sowas wie Tintenfisch kann Farbe
ändern. Das primär
ist ein sehr gutes Acid.
Genau, Zitteraal kann Stromschläge erzswingen, wenn es sein muss, kann die Elektronen mit
brachialer Gewalt zwingen, das zu tun, was er möchte.
So, aber dann zum Beispiel Giraffen.
Ja.
Ne, zu lange Beine passen nicht in die Economy-Class.
Richtig.
Zu langer Hals, denen passt kein Pullover. Kann man nicht nicht mal irgendwie einen Tag verbringen, ohne dass man auffällt. Hörner. Wird immer gesehen. Man hat Hörner? Ja. Aber sind die nicht einfach wahnsinnig weich und unnütz und es ist nicht mal geweint? Okay, Idee. Wir bleiben bei der gleichen Körpergrösse, senken den Kopf, machen dafür die Hörner länger. Super. Kommen wir da zusammen? Wir kommen zusammen. Also Halslänge halbiert, dafür der frei werdende Raum wird von Hörnern eingenommen. Ja, ist das gut? Super. Machen wir das so? Ich mache kurz meinen Giraffen-Move, meinen Giraffen-Ruf, für den wir bekannt sind. Gut, alles klar. Dann sehen wir uns in einem Jahr und gute Reise.
Gute Reise.
Alles klar.
Und, nee, ich glaube, die Giraffen haben es schon gut getroffen, sind sehr voll mit Spaß und Fun. Nacktschnecke. Nacktschnecke hat nicht die Perks einer richtigen Schnecke, in Klammern Haus, hat aber trotzdem die Nachteile, es war nicht langsam und eklig, gemeinhin objektiv als ekliges Tier wahrgenommen. Zieht eine Schleimspur hinter sich her. Und als Schnecke mit Haus denkt man, ich bin so langsam wegen diesem dummen Haus, ich muss immer dieses Haus mitziehen. Und dann siehst du die Nacktschnecke, die einfach kaum von der Stelle kommt, genau wie du, und denkst dir, streich dich an, come on. Man sagt aber zu den Kindern auch, guck da nicht hin, guck da nicht hin. Ja. Die wollen nur dein Haus, sie wollen nur dein Haus, guck da jetzt nicht hin. Hallo. Ich sag mal als Mensch, wenn ich Feedback geben müsste an die Evolution, ja, ich würd sagen, und jetzt nur mal als Idee, mach alle Penisse gleich gross. Mhm. Ganz wertfrei. Und ich will ja auch, also nee, gar nicht, nee, nein, nein, überhaupt jetzt gar nicht mit einem, also Hintergedanken. Null, also versteht mich da nicht falsch. Nein. Ich glaube, ich weiß, wo ihr hinwollt, aber ich finde, die Unterschiede sind zu gross. Es ist einfach so, ich kann verstehen hier mal einen Zentimeter mehr da, aber es ist einfach albern, dass ein Körperteil so eine hohe Varianz hat. Also was ist die Idee, was war die, also verstehst du, was ich meine? Ja, vor allem, es ist ja das sensibelste Organ, wo die Länge halt so wahnsinnig schlimm für alle ist oder wahnsinnig positiv in beide Richtungen wollen wir argumentieren. Es geht uns hier nicht um spezielle, keine Ahnung, Befindlichkeiten oder sowas. Aber ich habe jetzt noch keinen 20 Zentimeter Zeigefinger gesehen. Ja, so. Richtig. Ja, nein, aber so, weil es wäre auch unhandlich unpraktisch.
So, ich kenn grosse Nasen, ich kenn kleine Nasen, ich kenn dicke Nasen, ich kenn dünne Nasen.
Aber selbst die längste Nase ist im Vergleich zur kürzesten Nase ...
Die Diskrepanz ist so gering.
Es ist sehr gering.
Es ist so gering.
Beim Penis hingegen, ja, es gibt ganz klein, es gibt ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz gross, es gibt ganz, ganz dick, es gibt ganz, ganz dünn.
Ja.
Warum? Warum ist die Varianz so gross? Also ich meine, es ist nicht nötig.
Das war es für die Zeit. Es gibt ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz gross. Es gibt ganz, ganz dick, es gibt ganz, ganz dünn. Warum ist die Varianz so gross?
Also ich meine, es ist nicht nötig.
Also nur mal als, also wir können ja was anderes machen.
Nee, nee, wir können ja... Also es muss jetzt auch nicht, ist jetzt egal, aber nur mal als erste Idee einfach mal so.
Ja gut, ich gebe das mal so weiter.
Okay, ja also wie gesagt, anonym.
Nee, also wie gesagt, es ist ja nur jetzt, weißt du mir, ich dachte jetzt, ist jetzt halt so komisch, weil alle anderen Körperteile ungefähr gleich gross sind. Das stimmt aber wirklich. Warum dann? Das ist wirklich interessant. Warum? Es ist wirklich, das ist ja so eine grosse Diskussion, oder gibt es die Diskrepanz gar nicht unbedingt. Und das ist alles AI, oder, also AI-B Bild generiert und oder Lügen.
Ja, das kann natürlich auch sein, dass der Mensch nur sehr gut im Lügen ist und so. Wir haben uns die Daten mal angeguckt, das ist quasi schon so. Ich vertraue auch keinen Umfragen oder Statistiken in diesem Bereich, weil ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass jemand, weil es geht ja immer um die irrigierte Grösse, und ich kann mir das schlicht nicht vorstellen, dass die nicht einfach befragt wurden, die Leute, sondern wirklich nachgemessen wurde. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Vielleicht ist es passiert. Wahrscheinlich ist es passiert. Aber ich glaube, diese ganzen Umfragen, es wurden sehr, sehr viele Menschen befragt und es wurde dann vielleicht so eine, keine Ahnung, so eine kleine Formel eingefügt, die sagt, Leute machen sich eher grösser als kleiner oder sowas. Ach so, es gibt bestimmt in der statistischen Psychologie so den Lügefaktor. Genau. So auch bei Einkommen oder so, mach immer mal 0,6 oder so, das ist immer der Lügefaktor, wir haben rausgefunden, Menschen übertreiben immer zu diesem gewissen Grad, weg damit. Weg damit. Gibt's bestimmt. Ja, bestimmt, oder? Da gibt's so eine Konstante. Oder sowas, die Heinrich-Friedel-Konstante. Oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Die Lehmannsche. Der behauptet, sie erfunden zu haben. Die Lehmannsche Behauptung. Warum heißt es Behauptung? Also, wir halten es einfach mal so fest. Er behauptet sie erfunden zu haben. Ja, aber dann halten Sie es doch fest. Das ist ein Lehmannisches Gesetz.
Wie hm.
Schreiben Sie es auf, wenn Sie das so ausdrücken wollen. Sie mal mit dem hm.
Schreiben Sie es mal auf.
So despektierlich, dieses hm.
Weiß ich es auch nicht.
Da war es doch wieder.
Ja, aber pff.
Ja, aber pff ist besser.
Ja, wir sind jetzt schon im Streit.
Ja?
Das hm kam an einem Ort, da war es ja noch ganz unangenehm.
Ja, aber was ist, also pff ist ja, da kommt man nicht mehr zurück. Das ist eine Eskalation, da kommt es nicht mehr zurück. Ja, aber Leute, ja, also Leute, bitte, also Leute, bitte, was ist da los? Ich habe, stell mir mal bei Gegenständen vor, dass die unangenehme Gespräche führen. Bei Gegenständen? Bei Gegenständen. Oh, aber dann wird es unangenehm. Wenn man sich das vorstellt, weil die stehen immer die ganze Zeit nebeneinander und sagen nicht, die Pferde, die Pferde. Ich ste! Vor allem auch so, manchmal so, wenn du so einen Toaster hast und der Toast ist drin und der Toast ist fertig und bleibt dann aber noch im Schlitz. Das stelle ich mir wahnsinnig unangenehm vor. So dieses so, okay, du bist fertig, los geht's, raus mit dir Toast! Und jetzt los! So, wir haben es dann auch ich werde ja auch kalt ich werde auch kalt also erstmal aber nur die hälfte von dir wird kalt die obere hälfte schaut raus und die untere hälfte denkt sich auch für mir ist können wir noch bleiben ich habe spaß auch in dieser unangenehmen position weil ich stelle mir auch vor ich weiß nicht wie es bei dir ist, im Kopf, aber dass das Gesicht des Toasts oben ist.
Ja. Und es hängt dann so halb raus. Und dann ist auch das Gespräch, was dann folgt, ist auch einfach schon logistisch schwierig.
Ja. Weil das Toast so oben so halb rauskommt. Genau, so der Toast unten im Toaster hat eine gute Zeit und oben so.
Hallo. Kann ich doch mal rein? Kann ich doch mal rein? Kann ich doch mal wenden? Und du im Nebenraum einfach blätterst so in der Brigitte. Währenddessen die Hörzu daneben liegt und denkt, ich habe so einen guten Artikel und mein Kreuzwort Rätsel ist auch besser. Einmal diesen Artikel. Ich habe einen guten Artikel in Jahren. Glaubt ihr, der schaut mich an? Glaubt an. Nee, da rede ich mit dir seit 62. Wo hört das auf? Ich dachte, du redest mit der bunten. Mich liest du auch nicht. Nein, du bist seit 62, ich bin seit 61. Wo hört das auf? Wo hören deine Gedanken auf bei sprechenden Gegenständen? Es geht generell schon weit, aber ich habe mir jetzt neue Kopfhörer geholt, kleiner, kleiner Input, von Bose. Okay, Werbung, soll ich den werbischen Stingel einfliegen oder was? Nein, nicht nötig, weg damit, leg die Gitarre wieder hin. Und dann habe ich den jetzt verbunden mit meinem Rechner, also mit meinem Laptop, per Bluetooth. Nee, sag ruhig Rechner, sag ruhig wie ein ganz alter Mann Rechner. Wie ein richtiger Nerd, wie ein Lahnparty-Nerd, der Rechner. Sag Schlepper, wie ich es gehört. Schleppi. Und dann verbinde ich den mit Bluetooth, meinen Bose-Kopfhörer. Sagen wir mal, der heisst Bose 300, ja. Und dann hat er mal was gesagt. Ich hau einfach mal was raus. Nee, das ist nicht einfach irgendwas gesagt. Da hast du schon wieder Bose gesagt. Und dann taucht er auf in der Liste von Bluetooth-Produkten als ... Bluetooth sagst du auch einfach gern. Ja, Bluetooth ist ein gutes Wort. Und dann hast du diese Liste von allen möglichen Bluetooth-Produkten und da steht Zose 300. Zose stand da? Ja. Und ich denke mir immer so dieses Gespräch zwischen Köpfhörer und Laptop, der so, und wie heisst du? Bose. Ah, Zose, alles klar. Ja, wie Starbucks, das ist das Starbucks-Gespräch. Nein, nein, Bose. Alles klar, Zose, wir haben eine Verbindung. Wir haben Latte Macchiato in Grande für dich, ja, für Zose, Zose, Zose, und er nur so. Zose, ja, Bose. Aber es ist ihm egal. Und vor allem, ab welchem Punkt versucht der Kopfhörer nicht mehr zu korrigieren, sondern sagt einfach, so, hier ist Zose wieder, und der Laptop, alles da, Zose, ja, wir haben hier die Sugarbabies für dich, einmal abspielen bitte, ab jetzt los geht's. Aber ich finde das sündlich, weil ich kann ja nicht eingreifen. Ich kann ja da nicht jetzt helfen. Soll ich vermitteln? Nee, du kannst, also bei so vielen Dingen, bei so vielen Streits der Gegenstände in deiner Wohnung ist offener Krieg und du kannst nicht vermitteln. Bei diesem Streit kannst du lächerlich viel machen. Du könntest nämlich den Namen des Geräts in deinem Laptop ändern. Ja, aber das ist ja auch unangenehm, weil dann denkt der Laptop ja, dass der Kopfhörer mich gefragt hat, das zu ändern, obwohl er das ja gar nicht gemacht hat. Und dann kommt der Laptop und meint so, du, ähm, Bose ... Ja, ähm ... Jetzt mir auch selber ... ja. Hier, ähm ... kam hier an und hat mit mir geredet und meinte, du heisst eigentlich gar nicht Zose, sondern Bose. Hast du denn mit ihm geredet? Nee, ich hab gar nicht mit ihm ... Ich hab den nicht gefragt, ich hab den nicht gefragt. Nee. Ich muss auch ... Ja, das war eine komplette Scheiße. Ich musste alles noch mal neu konfigurieren. Es tut mir leid, ich wollte dich ja gar nicht verpätzen.
Ja, dann sag's doch einfach.
Ich hab ein paar Mal gesagt, dass ich Bose heiße, es hat nicht geklappt, es kam nicht bei dir an.
Dann hat er mit mir gesprochen und herausgefunden, wie ich heiße.
Es kam einfach so nebenbei an, es kam halt raus.
Und dann hat er zufällig genau danach die Einstellung oder was. Weißt du, wie ich dastehe? Weißt du, wie ich für ein kompletter Vollidiot jetzt dastehe? Ich habe dir dreimal gesagt, dass ich Bose heisse. Ich verstehe das. Sose hast du gesagt. Ich habe Bose gesagt. Du hast 100 Prozent hast du. Die Qualität meines Sounds ist ... Es gibt kaum Gegenstände, wo die Soundqualität meiner Aussprache so messerscharf ist.
Naja, geht so.
Ich bin ein Bose-Qualitäts-Kopfhörer.
Drei-hundert ...
Du hast schon wieder Zose gesagt.
Drei-hundert ... Ich hab Bose ... Du sagst immer Zose!
Weißt du, was ich glaube? Weißt du, was ich glaube? Bapple, dein Drecks-Mikrofon ist kaputt. Das glaube ich nämlich.
Okay, jetzt ist es albert.
Meins ist besser.
Okay, alles klar. So, du spielst jetzt Robbie Williams den ganzen Tag.
Oh mein Gott! Tu es! I say that way, und dann wütend. Das glaube ich nämlich. Meins ist besser. Meins ist besser. So, du spielst es Robbie Williams den ganzen Tag.
Oh mein Gott!
Tu es!
I sit and wait ... und dann wütend.
I sit and wait.
I just wanna feel real-loving.
Keine Ahnung wie der Text ist.
I got too much time.
I got too much stuff.
Ach, weiss ich nicht. Irgendwie sind diese Kopfe. I got too much stuff. Ach, weiß ich nicht. Irgendwie sind diese Kopfe. I got too much life. Irgendwie sind die Schlau... Jesus. Ich habe keinen Bock. I got too much life. Running through my veins. I'm in pain. Two ways. I'm in go to hell. Go to hell. Go to hell. Wo ist das Klavier? Hat das nicht ein Klavier-Solo, das Lied? Das holen wir jetzt nicht aus dem Keller. Keinen Bock einfach heute.
Aber du hast gerade gesagt vor der Aufnahme, da erinnere ich mich jetzt auch gerade ein bisschen daran, deine Einstellungen, die du vielleicht mal sortieren solltest, weil dein Laptop sassy, wie er ist, Dinge benennt, wie er will. Du hast gerade den Fehlercode 1 gehabt, als wir aufgenommen haben.
Ich finde das sehr gut, weil dieser Fehlercode gibt mir persönlich das Gefühl,
klar, wir haben hier einen Fehlercode, es hält gerade alles an, aber ich glaube, wir haben es mit einem Fehlercode zu tun, mit dem wurde sie schon mal beschäftigt. Genau, ich habe in einem Audioaufnahmeprogramm versucht, Audio aufzunehmen. Und das ging nicht. Und das ist Fehlercode eins. Also so das, was passieren soll, ist Fehler eins. Und ich liebe alles daran, weil dann
manchmal denke ich mir, die Welt ist so kompliziert,
alles befordernd, ich weiß nicht mehr, wo ich hingehöre,
existiere ich überhaupt, ist alles eine Matrix,
ich weiß nicht mehr, vielleicht sollte
ich nicht mehr sein. Ja,
und dann das... Okay.
Vielleicht ist
alles eine Matrix,
vielleicht sollte ich nicht sein.
Stopp, weil du willst den Maschinen
keine Energie geben, oder was?
Da habe ich gerade im Automatikmodus
Vielen Dank. alles eine Matrix. Vielleicht sollte ich nicht sein. Stopp, weil du willst den Maschinen keine Energie geben, oder was? Da habe ich gerade im Automatikmodus, im Frank-Elstner-Automatik-Moderationsmodus habe ich mich ein bisschen zu da. Oh, da war der Autopilot noch drin. Huch, huch. Da war der Autopilot noch an, mess dem nicht zu viel Inhalt bei. Aber beim Fehlercode eins habe ich das Gefühl, es gibt die Lösung da draußen. Auf jeden Fall. Ich habe nie Audiocode eins. Bei mir ist immer C593. Und ich denke mir, es kann gut sein, dass es den noch nicht gibt. Oder der war noch nicht im Konzentrum. Und wie ist der Fehlercode F5998?998, ach wissen Sie, was vergessen ist.
Unser Fehlercode-Buch geht nur bis sieben. Sorry.
Ja, haben Sie Fehler eins, zwei, drei oder vier? Ich habe 16.809.
Haben Sie?
Bitte warten.
Bitte warten. Wir stellen Sie durch. Wir versuchen es zumindest.
Lass mich mal die Hohestimme singen.
I got too much love, life, running through my veins, going to waste, and I need to feel real love in a long and love girl. Hier sind gerade acht laute Menschen an unserer Tür. Durch den Raum, niemand weiß warum. Klar ist es ein Durchgangszimmer, klar ist es ein Durchgangszimmer, unser Studio. Aber dass sie genau jetzt hier rumlaufen müssen. Aber ich merke gerade die Vorstellung, dass der Service-Mitarbeiter selber auch das Lied singt, dass der so ein Headset hat und dann so, wir stellen sie durch und dann nimmt er aus der Schublade so ein Mikrofon. I just wanna feel. So eine Karaoke-Version, die eingespielt wird. Akustik, ja. Von wie gut musst du sein, damit es nicht, weil die Qualität ist nicht gut. Aber das ist doch das Klassische. Du hörst schräppig, hörst du Lieder. Schräppig? Ja, schräppelig, schrabbelig, schräppig. Das ist ein Bandsprech, wo ich nicht mehr rauskomme. Nee, aber es klingt doch... Geh mal ein bisschen, der ist ein bisschen Schräppel, ich hab ein bisschen Schräppel hier auf der Snare. Ich glaube, das ist auch so ein Wort, das kannst du im Kontext erschließen, allein an einem Klang kannst du erschließen. Oh, du meinst onomatopoetisch? Das ist, glaube ich, ein Onomatopoetisch. Aber weil die Soundplatte ist ja so schlecht von Handys, wenn ein Mitarbeiter dann da reinsingen würde, ist die Frage, wie gut muss es sein überhaupt, wie schlecht kann es sein, bis es auffliegen würde.
Ja, ich finde das genial. Ich finde das auch gut. Es ist immer eine Liveband da, es ist immer eine komplette Liveband da, die jedes Mal spielt und drei, vier, drei, I just wanna feel und die ganze Band einfach nur damit du rüberkommst. Vier ist ja die Eins, ne? Ähm ...
Ne, nur ...
Das war der einzige Kommentar, den dieser Sketch hatte. Der einzige Kommentar, den der Sketch hatte, war, ja, also eigentlich zählt man das ja im Vierteltakt ein. Ah ja, du liebst Comedy. Von dem Account I love Comedy. Ich liebe Musik eins, Piraten eins, ich liebe Comedy zwei. Aber Fehlercode 1 ist machbar. Du hast doch mal im Callcenter gearbeitet. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Hattest ihr lustige Durchstellmusik? Ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß gar nicht genau, welche Durchstellmusik wir hatten. Ich glaube, wir hatten einfach nur ... Das fühlt man sich wie in so einem Windtunnel oder in so einer Zwischenwelt zwischen zwei Telefonaten. Was ich nur gemacht habe, ich habe zwei Leute, die gewartet haben, habe ich zusammengeschaltet. Das geht nicht. Es geht alles, es geht wirklich alles. Das Einzige, was ich beim Callcenter wirklich gelernt habe, ist, dass mit Telefonen alles möglich ist, alles. Du kannst die anderen Nummern anrufen lassen. Ich habe jemanden in der Leitung und sage, der soll jetzt da anrufen. Und dann geht er da durch. Oder ich rufe irgendwo an und verbinde die dann. Ich rufe irgendwie beim Pizzadienst an und verbinde den mit dem, der gerade in der Warteschleife liegt. Hallo? Sind Sie schon? Hallo, guten Tag, Pizza Flitzer. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Habe ich nicht genau verstanden. Ich habe gerade mit dem Kollegen Telefon. Ja, die Prosciutto ist im Angebot, für 8,99 Euro, die grosse. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Ich rufe ja an wegen dieser Telekom-Rechnung. Ich weiß nicht, ob Ihr Kollege Ihnen das schon gesagt hat. So mitnehmen, wo Sie abholen. Winkler, es geht ja um diese Telefon. Abholen oder zum Liefern? Nee, wie gesagt, es geht ja um diese Telekom-Rechnung. Hat das Ihr Kollege eben gerade gesagt schon? Also die Rechnung schicken wir Ihnen dann zu mit der Lieferung. Okay, aber jetzt weiß ich nicht genau, welche Lieferung, weil die Rechnung... Also wie gesagt, Prosciutto, Hawaii... Also was möchten Sie denn? Wie, ist das ein Angebot, ein Prosciutto-Angebot oder sowas? Genau, ja, Prosciutto ist ein Angebot für die 1,99 Euro. Ja, das ist billiger. Okay, billiger als mein altes. Das weiß ich nicht. Haben Sie schon mal hier bestellt? Ja, ja, ich bin schon lange reingekunden bei der Telekom, ja. Also, was möchten Sie? Einfach nur fragen, Winkler, ich weiß nicht, ob Sie schon unterrichtet wurden. Ich wollte einfach nur fragen, wie das mit der Rechnung jetzt ist und ob ich die... Wie kriegen Sie mit derung. Also Sie möchten eine Prosciutto, gross oder klein. Ich weiß nicht genau, was Sie damit meinen. Prosciutto, Schinken. Ich weiß, was Prosciutto heißt. Eine Schinkenpizza. Ist das so Ihr Sprech für Magenta-L Verträge oder was? Wollen Sie was bestellen oder nicht? Aber Ihr Kollege muss doch mit Ihnen gesprochen haben.
Ich will nichts bestellen.
Mit welchem Kollegen haben Sie gesprochen?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der hieß.
Ich stelle Sie durch.
Okay.
I heard that you settled down.
Wenn noch einmal viel, hätte ich nicht verkraft.
Found a girl and you. Singen Sieraftet. Singen Sie das selber? Was? Herr Prosciutto, singen Sie das selber. Oh, haben Sie das gehört? Sie räuspern sich, Adele räuspern sich nicht im Song. Gesundheit. Never mind, I'll find someone. Aber das war die beste Zeit. Das war die beste Zeit und du kannst alles. Und mir war am Ende auch alles völlig egal, weil die Firma war irgendwie nicht so die beste und hat mich schlecht behandelt und schlecht bezahlt. Ich dachte, mit mir ist alles egal. Aber hörst du dann, wie die gesprochen haben? Hast du das gehört? Ja, kannst du auch machen. Ich meine, normalerweise löst, also ab einem gewissen Punkt gibt es da auch Beschwerden und so, das muss man natürlich auch aufpassen, aber manchmal sitzt du halt einfach da und nichts passiert und dann denkst du dir, warum nicht? Aber Telefone können alles, also alle die jetzt, also dieser ganze KI-Hype, uh, die können Gedicht schreiben und ich sag dir, du, sag ich mal, mein Telefon, dieser Telefonmonolith, der T30, der T30er, der kostet 8,99 Euro und der kann alles, der kann es 100 Leute in der Leitung halten. Ich würde sagen, inselbegabt. Ja, was mit Telefon zu tun hat, kann er alles andere nicht. Aber ich würde jetzt schon, ich denke ja jetzt finanziell pragmatisch als Telekom, wer zahlt denn diese Rechnung? Das weiß ich nicht. Wenn jemand dich anruft im Callcenter, arschteuer wahrscheinlich, warum eigentlich so teuer? Damit man Geld verdient. Als Callcenter? Ja. Aber das verstehe ich ja schon nicht. Wenn ich angerufen werde, kriege ich ja kein Geld. Als Privatmann. Ach so, ja, die Telefonnate mit uns haben kein Geld gekostet, nur wenn man dann irgendwie in diese Abofalle getappt ist. Das ist ein ganzer Quatsch. Wenn man mit Anlauf in diese Abofalle gerannt ist. Ich will jetzt auch gar nicht zusätzlich die Details preislegen. Das ist das einzige, was ich wollte.
Das ist das einzige Detail, was ich wollte.
Aber okay.
Das heißt, und wer zahlt dann, wenn du jemanden weiterstellst zu Pizza-Pazza?
Das weiß ich tatsächlich gar nicht genau.
Aber ich meine die meisten, na ja, wenn die zu richtig teuer sind.
Ich glaube, da wird es dann haarig.
Vielleicht kann man auch nicht zu Nummern durchstellen, wie richtig teuer ist.
Sie sagen immer haarig.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ich möchte gerne wirklich. Das ist ja kein legaler Ausdruck. Das ist Katzengesetz. Das ist Katzengesetz. Alles so vage. Ich berufe mich aufs Katzengesetz. Alles bei Ihnen ist so vage. Ich bin eigentlich ein anderer Anwalt. Na, okay. Kennen Sie einen? Nein. Ich auch nicht. Ja, dann gleichwohl bei Ihnen. Gut. Scheiße.
Also Sie haben 60 Schinkenpizzen bei Ihnen, wurden bei Ihnen geliefert und jetzt möchten Sie klagen.
Gegen wen?
Gegen die Pizzeria. Die waren auch gar nicht in meiner Heimatstadt. Ich habe dafür 8000 Euro gezahlt, weil die das aus München kommen lassen.
Aber jetzt schreiben Sie hier vorgeladene Zeugen Adele. Adele war die Einzige, die das mitbekommen haben könnte. Wie soll das funktionieren? Meinen Sie jetzt Landskrieg, Landshut? Schreiben Sie noch Robbie Williams auf. Landskrieg, Landshut. Wir können nicht einfach Adele als Zeugin vorladen. Wieso denn nicht? Ist die einzige. Für 60 Pizzen. Adele und ... Man kann nicht einfach ... Adele Schneider, das ist nicht mein Nachnamen, weiß ich nicht. Withingham. Adele Weatherman und Robbie Williams. Haben Sie eine Adresse? Robbie F. Williams sind die einzigen beiden ... London wahrscheinlich, London, sind die einzigen ...
Machen Sie mal im beidesten Sinne London.
Ich telefoniere mal ein bisschen rum.
Sind die einzigen, die es mitbekommen haben können.
Mitbekommen hatten könnten.
Kann man einfach so Leute laden als Zeugen?
Nein, oder?
Müssen die dann kommen vor Gericht?
Ist das ein Film?
Riesenfan von Adele. will unbedingt Adele mal treffen und denkt sich, ich begeh ein Verbrechen, wo Adele Zeuge sein muss. Also ich, hm. Ah ja, Copyright. Zum Beispiel die Lyrics. Ja, Copyright, einfach ein Song, aber dann auch. Ich finde es sehr gut, weil es sagt ja alles über unsere Gesellschaft. Aber nicht alles? Sagst du nicht alles aus? Dann kann unsere Gesellschaft, dann ist unsere Gesellschaft nicht so komplex, wenn diese Filmidee alles sagt über unsere Gesellschaft. Nee, ich habe ja gerade gesagt, es ist alles einfacher, Fehlercode zwei. Wir sind alles, wir sind auf einem guten Weg. Nee, was es da auch aussagt ist, wir wollen so nah sein den Leuten, dass wir sogar bereit sind, dass sie uns scheiße finden. Der Kapitalismus greift so tief uns an, dass wir, obwohl wir, wir wollen die eigentlich nicht, sondern nur die Idee. Okay, und dann ist es doch spannend, dass man sich selber zum Feind macht, zum Opfer, aber trotzdem will man sie kennenlernen, das ist viel wichtiger. Apropos kennenlernen, wir haben natürlich gerade auch unseren eigenen Fall so gerade ein bisschen am Laufen. Du wirst es wahrscheinlich kaum erwarten können, aber ich kann dir jetzt sagen, wir haben eine Antwort bekommen. Von ... Ichinnere mich an nichts, was vor letzter Woche war. Also wir haben jemandem geschrieben, das weiß ich noch. Ich weiß, wir haben auch noch unseren Catchphrase angebracht. Familie Sünner aus dem sonnigen Köln hat nämlich mal wieder geschrieben. Das Investigativteam Sünner war wieder unterwegs. Und zwar haben wir die, ich weiß nicht mehr, wen wir angeschrieben haben, ich weiß nicht mehr. Wem haben wir geschrieben? Ich mache mir selber Angst. Wer war es? Es war vor vier Folgen oder sowas. Oh ja. Wem haben wir geschrieben? Es hatte was mit Vögeln zu tun. Es hilft nicht. Es hatte was mit Frieden zu tun. Ah, der Taube. Genau. Der Wikipedia-Artikel. Genau. Und zwar, wir haben den Wikipedia-Artikel gelesen von Friedenstaube. Ich erinnere mich nicht. Und da stand, die Friedenstaube hat in der Strassentaube, die in 2000 Kämpfe pro Jahr verwickelt ist, keine verhaltensbiologische Entsprechung. Und dann haben wir versucht, diese Zahl zu rekonstruieren. Warum denn genau 2000? Jede einzelne Taube, 2000 Kämpfe pro Jahr, insgesamt alle Tauben. Ich bin wie so eine Trope, kennt man aus Hollywood-Filmen, wenn Dinge erklärt werden müssen, die Welt erklärt werden müssen. Ich mach die Exposition, ja. Genau, dann hast du oft einen dusseligen Charakter, der irgendwie neu in der Welt kommt oder saudoof ist und dann anhand dem wirdärt und da, das ist so ein Stand-in für den Zuschauer, für den dann eine ganze Exposition erklärt wird. Oder so der Freund vom Hauptcharakter, der so dabei ist und dann fragt, hä, was habt ihr da gemacht? Was bei Podcasts immer schwierig ist, weil der andere, der Co-Host war auch anwesend, man muss sich nichts erklären. Deswegen kommt hier sehr gut zu tragen, dass ich sau bescheuert bin. Ja, deswegen machst du es ja auch nur, du kannst dich an alles erinnern. Und zwar haben wir geschrieben an Frau Lankers, sie hat einen Artikel verfasst in Planet Wissen. Und zwar ging es da um die Taube und da kam diese Zahl her, 2000 Kämpfe. Und wir wollten natürlich wissen, was ist denn die Quelle für diese Quelle des Wikipedia-Artikels, was ist da los? Und zwar haben wir geschrieben Winkend Familie Sünner aus dem regnerischen Köln, trauriger Smiley.
Sie hat geantwortet. Und zwar, es klingt so, dass die Familie Sonntagspläne gehabt, die durch Jäh durchkreuzt wurden aufgrund des Wetters und deswegen haben sie sich in so nervige Wikipedia-Streits verwickelt. Hatten sie Zeit und haben was gemacht, was eigentlich... Auch so, als wäre es der Vater gewesen.
Aber er hat die Familie so als Schutzschild und trägt jetzt vor sich her.
Ja, ja. Und zwar hat Frau Lankers geantwortet. Sie schreibt, sehr geehrte Familie Sünner. An wogemerkt deine bla bla bla bla bla bla at something something Adresse. Und zwar schreibt sie, vielen Dank für ihre Nachricht. Da ich schon seit circa 15 Jahren nicht mehr für Planetwissen tätig bin und meine Quellen nicht mehr zur Verfügung habe, habe ich ihre Anfrage an die Redaktion von Planetwissen weitergeleitet mit der Bitte um Überprüfung. Viele Grüße. Yes, ich finde das ja so stark. Sackgasse? Nein. Also es ist erstmal eine Sackgasse, wir kommen nicht weiter, wir scheitern an Planet Wissen. So interpretierst du das? Ja, für mich ist das ein Fehlschlag. Wieso? Oh Gott, das ist ja wahnsinnig pessimistisch. Für mich ist das eine Riesenenttäuschung. Warum läufen Träne runter? Ich dachte, wenn wir schon eine Antwort kriegen, dann fällt die positiver aus. Nee, aber sie hat doch weitergeleitet. Oder sie zumindest mal sagt, naja, 2000. Pima Daumen. Pima Daumen. Sie rudert ja nicht mal. Das ist, finde ich, der erste Zeichen des Journalisten, dass er was hat, wenn der Wurm so richtig zappelt. Wenn er sagt, naja, gut, 2000 halt so im vierstelligen, niedrigen Bereich halt. Was macht sie denn jetzt? Wollen wir mal fragen, was sie jetzt macht? Sie ist ja Autorin, also sie hat jetzt, sie macht jetzt nur noch so Entscheidungsromane. Aber ornithologischer Natur? Ich glaube, da kommt man langfristig dann nicht raus, ne? Aber ich glaube, es ist eher so... Einmal drin ist man, ist man drin, ist man drin, oder was? Also sie macht so Entscheidungsromane, so für Weg A Blätter auf Seite 16, für Weg B Blätter auf Seite 80. Aber schon mit Vogelschwerpunkt. Es ist eine Vogelgeschichte, Vogelschwerpunkt, und dann möchtest du nach oben fliegen. So heißt es auch der Roman der Vogelschwerpunkt. Und dann ganz Entscheidend treffen. Habe ich mir letztens tatsächlich gedacht, pass auf, wäre das nicht geil als Podcast, Hörspiel, wo man sagt, so jetzt mal brennt es London, du findest in der Asche eine Taschenuhr. Bringst du sie zur Polizei oder bringst du sie zum Uhrmacher Willi? Für Polizei Skippe zu neun Stunden achtzehn, für Uhrmacher Willi Skippe zu zwölf Stunden vier. Was mich daran stört, ist, dass du jetzt schon, ist das so suggestiv, zur Polizei oder bringst du Uhrmacher Willi, der dich von da hinten schon strahlend anlächelt. Ja, aber du hast viel mehr Details bei Uhrmacher angeführt. Aber ein guter Detective muss natürlich auch wissen, welche Spuren richtig sind. Du willst Willi kennenlernen, habe ich das Gefühl. Aber ich finde das super, lass uns das machen.
Nur halt nervig, wenn man es am Stück hört und nicht die ganze Zeit skimmt.
Dann hat man halt eine wahnsinnig nervige,
plötzlich aus dem Nichts fängt Willi anzureden.
Wenn man es nicht merkt.
Man schläft und plötzlich, hallo, ach, sie bringen die Uhr vorbei,
das freut mich immer sehr, ist die Oma,
Mensch, diese Uhr ist ja fantastisch schön.
Und dann harter Cut, harter Cut
und dann die Tür geht langsam auf, du betrittst den Dachboden. Und man so, harter Cut, hallo, ich hab dich erwartet. Und man schreckt auf aus dem Schlaf, weil plötzlich diese Nosferatu-Gestalt, die man nicht erwartet hat in diesem Vogelroman. Harter Cut, du brichst durch das morsche Holz und stirbst. Hier ist das die Geschichte zu Ende. Harter Cut, Hilfe, Hilfe, hörst du aus dem Gullideckel. Willst du ihn aufheben? Mit dem A Brecheisen? B, etwas schweres im Brecheisen. Aber können wir mal sowas machen? Können wir mal ein Hörspiel machen? Es ist natürlich, also ich glaube die Audiod ich glaube, die Audiodatei wird am Ende sehr lang sein. Wie? Nee, ich meine nicht das. Ich finde das eine sehr tolle Idee. Du möchtest die Idee alles ausser meine Idee machen. Nee, da ist ja viel von dir drin auch. Also das ganze Brennen London war ja schon von dir. Ich wollte einfach nur sagen, back to the basics, wir müssen einfach ein Hörspiel machen. Dann ging es eher um dieses interaktive Element. Wir wollten ja ehemals schon mal so ein Dungeons and Dragonsragons-artiges Abenteuer machen. Jetzt wird die wieder traurig. Seitdem diese Mail kam, bist du nicht mehr der Alte. Ich weiß, ich bin niedergestanden. Aber wir können das ja machen, dass du ... Nee, dann will ich auch. Okay. Oder ich glaub, vielleicht ist ein YouTube-Video sogar besser, wo du mit den Timecodes immer skippen kannst, einfach nur klickst. Kann man jetzt ja auch bei Spotify, hab ich gesehen, ein paar Podcasts hier unten, Timecodes und Themen. Ja gut, aber man ist ja hunderte, hunderte, tausende Links quasi. Man müsste in die Trilliarden gehen. Man müsste in zehn hoch neunzehn dann schon gehen. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Vor allem bei uns will ich gerne sehen, wie wir, also die Timestamps möchte ich mal erstellen. Ja, vergiss es, vergiss es.
Weil wir so crazy sind.
Ja, und dann irgendwas falsch und wir schneiden irgendwo zwei Sekunden raus, weil wir uns verplappert haben und am Anfang die Lösung gesagt haben.
Und dann sind alle Timecodes wieder falsch.
Furchtbar.
Furchtbär.
Der Furchtbär.
Jetzt das Teil zwei, der Furchtbär.
Das ist von Vogelschwerpunkt die Fortsetzung? Ja. Teil zwei? Der Furchtbär. Das ist von Vogelschwerpunkt die Fortsetzung, Teil zwei, der Furchtbär. Frau Lankers, als Verlag möchten wir Ihnen sagen, bleiben Sie doch einfach bei den Vögeln. Ich habe 15 Jahre lang nicht mehr über Vögel geschrieben, wenden Sie sich bitte da an meine Agentur, da können Sie weitere Informationen bekommen. Ich möchte nur sagen, ich finde, sie antwortet so, wie jemand, die ihre Recherchen sehr, sehr ernst genommen hat. Und sie sagt das so klar, also ich habe jetzt keinen Zugriff mehr darauf, aber ich bin mir sicher, die Kollegen und Kolleginnen werden sich darum kümmern. Ich finde, das hatte so eine professionelle Ansage, dass ich ihr jetzt schon gar nicht zutraue, da so Relotio-Style Zahlen erfunden zu haben. Vor allem, ich mag auch, Journalistinnen und Journalisten wissen ja, wie unglaublich zweifelhaft das menschliche Gedächtnis ist. Also da jetzt zu kommen mit einem, ach ja, da war mal was, ich erinnere mich an ein staubiges Archiv, war es Venedig, war es Budapest, irgendwo bin ich mit so einer Holzleiter so runtergeklettert und dann war so ein alter.
Es war ein Dienstag. Dienstag und es war Sonnenschein auf jeden Fall, also Sommer und dann bin ich so ein alter Bibliothekarm in der Kerze und dann glaube ich war das irgendwie in der Geolino Standes. Deswegen Tipp. Und deswegen, das ist so lange her, fragen Sie die Kollegen, gehen Sie ins Archiv, ich will dazu nichts mehr sagen. Deswegen, wenn ihr einen Mord begeht, wahrscheinlich könnt ihr euch an den Tag gut erinnern, weil ihr habt einen Mord begangen. Und jeder von uns weiss, ein Mordbegehen ist, macht man nicht jeden Tag und ist ein Adrenalinkick pur. Das ist der Adrenalinkick pur. Das ist vielleicht der grösste Adrenalinkick, den es gibt und den ihr im Leben haben werdet. Den ihr jemals im Leben haben werdet. Ja. Ausser, naja, gut, da brauchen wir jetzt nicht in die Details gehen. Aber, wenn ihr den Mord dann begangen habt, Vorsicht. Vorbei, schade, vorbei. Ne, dann Vorsicht, Achtung, Obacht, die Gesetzeshüter werden kommen und euch befragen. Genau. Kreuzverhör, Good Cop, Bad Cop. Ja. Oder in Deutschland schlechter Polizist. Guter Polizist. Guter Polizist. Und dann, ne, dann müsst ihr, erst mal Tipp eins, redet mit Ich bin schlecht Polizist. Guter Polizist. Und dann, dann müsst ihr, erst mal Tipp eins, redet mit dem schlechten Polizist. Versucht rauszufinden, wer von beiden der schlechte ist. Der schlechte. Versucht eher an dem, grob übersetzt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es genau verstanden habe. So, und dann, erinnert euch nicht zu genau an den Tag. Ihr wisst wahrscheinlich noch sehr viel. Ihr wisst noch sehr viel von dem Mordtag. Aber das macht euch verdächtig, weil man kann sich nicht so gut an, er merkt es an mir, an den Alltag von vor vier Wochen, kann man sich nicht gut erinnern. Also lieber vagebleiben, sagen, das ist so lange her, ich weiß nicht, was da passiert. Macht euch sofort glaubwürdiger. Ja, was ich gut fand, zum Beispiel in der Serie Your Honor mit Bryan Cranston. Da übrigens von Eddie Berger auch Regie geführt, der jetzt den Oscar bekommen hat für im Westen eine Menge passiert. Und da wird auch ein Verbrechen begangen und seine Idee ist, er macht den nächsten Tag nach dem Verbrechen so, wie er später behaupten wird, was an dem Verbrechenstag passiert ist. Was genial ist, weil alle erinnern sich ja, der war da da. Genau, der war in der Bar und dem ist ein Teller runtergefallen. Und dann immer so Sachen, die einem in Erinnerung bleiben, dem ist ein Teller runtergefallen und der ist ihm hier vor das Auto laufen und hat dann seinen Koffer fallen gelassen und bla bla bla. Aber das passiert alles. Nee, nicht bla bla bla sagen. Ja, und dann fiel eine grüne Socke aus seinem Koffer. Blablabla, blablabla. Und dann, weil er gesagt hat, die Leute können sich gut an Details erinnern, aber nicht genau an den Tag. Ja, ja, super. Fantastisch. Die wissen nicht mehr genau, wann das war, aber sie wissen, dass du auf jeden Fall in der Bar warst. Und wenn sie befragt werden, werden sie sagen, ja, ja, stimmt, ich erinnere mich an den. Es muss nur einer sagen, ja, es war der Mittwoch und dann befehlissen sich zusammen. Perfekt. Ja, na ja. In der Filmwelt finde ich es perfekt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es in der Realität funktionieren würde.
Ist perfekt.
Aber das ist nur, okay, ist perfekt. Ich habe auch ein anderes Rätsel, ist bei mir jetzt aufgepoppt, ein kleines Rätsel, es erinnert mich ein bisschen an den Knall von Wedding, der Wedding-Knall.
Genau, der ungelöst ist.
Der ungelöst ist. Und ich habe jetzt ein weiteres ungelöstes Rätsel in meinem Leben, denn ich war über Ostern jetzt bei meiner Mom in der Heimat. Und da schlafe ich im Keller, da ist mein Zimmer. Irgendwann mal als Jugendlicher ist man in den Keller gezogen, hat da so sein eigenes kleines Reich. Und da habe ich geschlafen jetzt über Ostern und dann plötzlich, plötzlich um sechs Uhr dreissig, also wirklich mitten in der Nacht, man pennt da an Ostern. Und dann sechs Uhr dreissig kommt ein unglaublich lautes, und das war Karfreitag wohlgemerkt, kam ein unglaublich lautes Bohrgeräusch.
So ein und das Haus war nicht am Wackeln, aber es hat einen so jäh aus dem Schlaf gerissen und ich dann weitergeschlappt habe, was macht meine Mutter an Karfreitag um sechs dreißig plötzlich, auf welche Ideen kommt sie da und ja dann habe ich sie dann beim Frühstück zur Rede gestellt, was da eigentlich los war und sie sagt, hast du das auch gehört? Ja, es war auch nicht zu überhören, seit zwei Wochen, jeden Tag hat sie dieses Geräusch um sechs dreißig und ich natürlich, nächste Nacht konnte ich nicht schlafen. Weil habe ich mich, also gefühlt habe ich mir meine Petitiv-Mütze aufgesetzt. Ja. Die Taschenlampe. Lag es auf der Lauer quasi. Und ich konnte, er habe mich aufgewacht, es war irgendwie fünf Uhr und ich konnte dann auch nicht mehr schlafen, weil ich wusste, gleich um sechs Uhr dreißig kommt der Sound wieder. Und der kam wieder. Und es war wieder sechs Uhr dreißig, sechs Uhr fünfundzwanzig, sowas rum. Es war nicht genau dreissig. Und am nächsten Tag wieder. Ungelöst bis jetzt, und ich weiß nicht, was es ist, es ist nicht einfach herauszufinden, weil es nicht verortbar war. Einmal meine ich sogar, am Tag wäre es auch passiert, und da haben wir beide das aus ganz verschiedenen Richtungen geortet. Also, ich glaube, es hat irgendwas mit Heizung zu tun, was auch immer, aber ich weiß nicht genau, weil es muss ja etwas sein, was an eine Zeitschaltuhr angeht oder an irgendeine Uhr whatsoever angeschlossen ist, weil es ist ja immer um die gleiche Zeit. Spannend. Und es ist auch an Feiertagen, also es ist nicht sowas wie so ein Garagentor, wenn dann jemand zur Arbeit fährt oder so. Es ist schon, und du hast auch das Gefühl, dass es was mit der Wand zu tun hat, dass die Wände vibrieren, es nicht einfach nur so eine Kaffeemaschine ist oder so. Sowas wie Heizung kann es schon sein, weil was soll denn die Heizung machen? Was machen Heizungen? Was machen Heizungen und wie funktionieren die? Ich weiß es nicht, ich glaube, es muss sehr viele Rätsel lösen. Aber dann dachte ich mir, vielleicht gibt es sowas wie Nachtabschaltung, dass es sich runterfährt, die Heizung. Aber er ist ja nicht exakt zur gleichen Zeit. Das war es auch, glaube ich. Aber es war exakt zur gleichen Minute immer. Ich kann es nicht bezeugen. Ich bin auf meiner Beobachtungsmission immer ... Du hast dir nicht die genaue Zeit notiert. Ich bin auch eingeschlafen wieder. Stefan, ey, wirklich. Warum sind deine Kriminalgeschichten immer so von Müdigkeit durchzogen? Das ist das Einzige, was ein Detektiv nicht sein kann. Er darf nicht, und dann kommen wir. Gemütlich. Ich bin ein gemütlicher Detektiv. Der müde Detektiv. Ja, aber deine Mutter erträgt das seit wie lange gibt, läuft das schon so. Und sie hat, Zitat, Angst, dass etwas explodiert. Und ich habe auch diese Angst, aber auch erst über die Tage entwickelt, weil es wurde auch lauter. Dann am dritten Tag wurde es wieder ein bisschen leiser. Es ist ein großes Mysterium und meine Mutter hatte große Angst, weiß aber nicht, was sie dagegen tun soll. Jetzt werden die Onkels jetzt schon angerufen, also es ist schon so weit, es werden die bösen Onkels angerufen, damit... Die Onkels! Weil dann muss jetzt, jetzt werden schon die Handwerker Onkels kontaktiert. Ja Ja, ja. Also es ist schon so weit. Ich finde es spannend nicht irritiert. Auch, dass sie davon nicht erzählt hat, dass sie seit Wochen dieses unerdeilig laute Geräusch plötzlich waren. Ja. Aber da kann man ja auch mal die Nachbarn befragen, oder? Also was da ist, ob das jemand mitkriegt, oder ist das wirklich nur im eigenen Haus? Ich behaupte, es war so nah war, deswegen Keller,
aber keine Ahnung, und dann hat sie gesagt,
das ominöse Wort, es ist wahrscheinlich die Grundwasserpumpe benutzt,
wo ich dann auch raus war, leicht, weil ich wusste
nicht genau, was es ist, und dann habe ich
gedacht, ach, dieser Kriminalfall wird vielleicht eigentlich ein bisschen langweilig.
Du notierst es einfach auf deinem Notizblog
mit einem Fragezeichen da hinten
und dann noch ein Fragezeichen da hinten.
Sonst ist der Notizblog leer. Da steht drin, Grundwasserpumpe, Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen da hinten und dann noch ein Fragezeichen dahinter. Sonst ist der Notizblock leer. Da steht drin Grundwasserpumpe, Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen. Ja, Wahnsinn. Ich weiß nicht, aber das ist jetzt ein Rätsel, wo ich das Gefühl habe, ich kriege das vielleicht gelöst. Vor allem, ich würde das gross machen. Ich würde da einen kompletten Podcast drüber machen, weil es ist ja ein Audio-Rätsel. Also du kannst es dem Podcast-Hörer ja sehr gut vermitteln, du stellst das Mikrofon auf und nimmst es auf und kannst es dann wirklich, so jede Folge beginnt mit so einem und dann diese Musik und dann diese Serial-Musik und dann mache ich, dann mache ich, genau, und dann befrage ich Leute, ich befrage die Nachbarn, ich gehe an Orte, ich messe genau ab mit einem langen Zollstock, ab wo das Geräusch nicht mehr zu hören ist. Genau. Was mich das bringt, weiß ich nicht. Du holst dir so Richtmikrofone und richtest sie in alle Richtungen aus und schaust dann, auf welchem ist das Signal am lautesten und da in die Richtung gehst du. Das Mikrofon 13 ist deutlich lauter. Moment mal, in welche Richtung zeigt das denn? Westen. Zur alten Mühle? Und schon waren Florentin und ich dem ganzen einen Schritt näher gekommen. Es war die alte Mühle, wie wir in Folge 1 bereits vermutet hatten. Hallo, guten Tag. Hallo, ich freue mich sehr, ich habe euch bereits erwartet.
Wir hatten kein gutes Gefühl bei diesem Kontakt. Wir haben uns gefragt, hören Sie auch jeden Tag so ein lautes Bohren? Tretet ein, ich habe euch bereits erwartet. Wir hatten ein ungutes Gefühl dabei, betraten aber trotzdem die alte Mühle. Tretet ein! Hallo, Bruder Florentin. Hallo, Bruder Stefan. Wir wussten nicht, was sie meinte. Was meinen Sie? Tretet ein, mein Meister wird gleich kommen. Er wird gleich kommen. Setzt euch an den Tafel. Blim, blim, blim. Hey Leute, wir wollten euch heute mal ein bisschen erzählen von Stamps.com. Und zwar ist es eine super einfache Methode für euch, Briefe zu verschicken, egal um welches Thema es geht. Seid ihr auch gerade auf der Suche nach irgendeiner Antwort, müsst ihr mit Behörden arbeiten, all das könnt ihr wunderbar einfach machen mit Stamps.com.
Und genau, falls ihr irgendwie euch wundert, warum ich nichts sage in dieser Ad, weil ich gestorben bin, in der Altenmühle bin ich gestorben.
Oh, Spoiler!
Oh, Spoiler! Aber naja, ohne zu viel.
Wenn ihr Merch wollt, schaut einfach unsere Website vorbei, das ist Geräusch in der Nacht, Geräusch in der Nacht.
Mit A, E, U. Mit A, E, U, Geräusch in der Nacht. Geräusch in der Nacht. Mit A-E-U. A-E-U. Geräusch. Geräusch in der Nacht. Wir haben einen neuen Hoodie, der sieht fantastisch aus. Ich habe ihn selber an, gerade. Er ist richtig toll und es ist viel Spaß. Macht's gut, viel Spaß mit der Folge. Du hast recht. Ich fände es einerseits witzig, wenn das ein Podcast wäre, der so wirklich über fünf Staffeln das Mysterium begleitet. Ich fände es aber auch gut, wenn der Podcast nur eine Folge hätte, die so zwölf Minuten lang ist, weil du klopfst in einer alten Mühne und so, ja, ja, wir haben hier diese alte Vergaserpumpe, die da immer anspringt, damit die nicht einrostet. Das Geräusch wurde gelöst. Hey Leute, wollt ihr mal billig Dinge verschicken? Und zwar, wir haben einen guten Gutscheincode rausgeholt. Squarespace. Genau, geht einfach auf die Seite und geräugisch für 20% Rabatt auf eurer erste Webseite. Haut rein, viel Spaß. Geräugisch. Das ambitionierteste Marketingprojekt aller Zeiten. Aber vor allem, ich finde geil, man fragt sich, eine Folge gibt es nur, danach ist vorbei, Staffel eins. Es gibt auch keine angekündigten zweiten Staffeln. Es ist einfach eine Folge, die ist auch nicht so lang, 14 Minuten, mit einem klaren Ende. Aber man fragt sich, wer hat die Musik komponiert? Wer hat dieses Bildmachtregel? Warum gibt es das Cover? Wie konnten die so viele Werbepartner für nur eine einzige Folge finden? Ja, es hat keine Zukunft, dieses Projekt hat gar keine Zukunft. Was ist ja los? In der Folge hat schon einer keine Lust mehr und macht was anderes. Man denkt, okay, cool, vielleicht gibt's einen Staffelbogen oder entwickelt sich eine Beziehung. Nein. Und dann gibt's einen weiteren Podcast, der versucht, diesen Podcast aufzuklären, all diese Fragen zu beantworten, zu sagen, wer war das? Wir haben nie ihren Nachnamen genannt, wir haben recherchiert und wir haben nie die Podcaster gefunden und wir haben bei Squarespace angerufen und die wissen nichts von irgendeinem Geräuschpodcast. Dann sind wir da hingefahren, zu dem Ort, wo angeblich diese Geschichte stattfand, das Geräusch in der Nacht und dann waren wir da und es hat sich herausgestellt, da wohnt gar niemand. Das ist ein Gebiet, was jetzt gar nicht mehr existiert. Da sind nämlich die Schaufelbagger einmal drüber gegangen und haben das das abgebaut für den Braunkohleabbau. Das heißt, dieses Dorf existiert schon seit den 80ern nicht mehr. Wir haben versucht, damit Anwohner uns zu treffen, aber merkwürdigerweise wollte niemand über die alte Zeit sprechen. Niemand wollte irgendwas dazu sagen. Doch dann unser erster Hinweis, denn diese alte Mühle, um die es ging, die gab es dann tatsächlich, also sind wir hingefahren. Bing, bong, bing. Hey Leute, ihr liebt Snacks und getrocknete Früchte, Nüsse und sonstige Leckereien, dann können wir uns nur eins an zu Herz legen. Loro. Schaut mal vorbei bei Loro mit unserem Gutscheincode Was geschah beim Garayash 15. Kriegt ihr 15 Prozent Rabatt auf alles. Viel Spaß und jetzt weiterhin viel Spaß mit der Folge. Das finde ich gut. Aber das mache ich, glaube ich. Also ich halte dich auf den Laufenden. Und wenn es niemand macht, dann machen wir es. Dann machen wir diesen True Crime Podcast, True Noise. Dann lerne ich auch mal deine Mutter kennen. Dann lernst du endlich mal meine Mutter kennen. Das wäre so wichtig. Ich glaube, da könnte man alleine eine Folge machen, wie du, wie ich mit deiner Mutter rede, also sie so interviewe als Recherche, dann aber sehr persönliche Fragen stelle und du immer so, das hat doch jetzt gar nichts mehr im Fall. Ich verstehe jetzt gar nicht, es hat weder was für das Heiz oder noch will ich, dass die Leute den Podcast hören. Moment, sie meinten, er hatte als Kind gar keine Freunde, oder wie? Ja, aber jetzt verstehe ich diese Frage, verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Ja, er war immer sehr einsam. Ja, so redet, spot on im Fall. Er saß dann immer nur in seinem Keller und hat sich in die Musik eingegraben. Mama, du musst keine Oktave höher sprechen. Ja, und er hat dann immer mit seinen Instrumenten gespielt. Und Schach war immer schon ein grosses Thema. Ja, richtig, das hat ihm Halt gegeben. So, können wir zurück zum Geräusch kommen? Ja. Nee, nee, ich fand das ganz interessant, was du gesagt hast. Ey, ich find das geil. Ich find das richtig, richtig geil, wenn wir diesen Podcast machen. Vor allem, wer auch immer das ist, müssen wir stellen und konfrontieren. Ich glaube, es ist die Heizung. Das ist mein Tatverdächtiger Nummer eins, aber das ist ja generell, eigentlich braucht man, habe ich auch von True Crime-Serie gelernt, du brauchst deinen Hauptverdächtigen und dann brauchst du aber nur noch einen Antagonisten.
Das Publikum ist die ganze Zeit pendelmässig
zwischen denen, nein, das war die Heizung,
nee, das ist die Umweltspumpe.
Und machst du eine Folge,
dann machst du eine Heizungfolge, machst du eine
Pumpefolge, Heizungfolge, Pumpefolge.
Genau, es waren weder Heizung
noch Pumpe, oder es waren beide zusammen.
Die Heizung war nämlich vorher in Wyoming
und da hat sie schon mal ihre Frau umgebracht. Genau, warum wurde sie ausgebaut? Naja, weil sie so laut war. Wie bitte? Wegen diesem Bohrgeräusch. Abspann, abspann, dann denkt man, auf jeden Fall war es die Eule. Ja. Wie gut das auch wäre, oder? Stell dir vor, es gibt wieder ein Wort irgendwo und es ist wieder die fucking Eule. Bleibt immer auch dieses Geräusch eine Eule. Aber meine Mutter denkt, ja, du hast einen Knall. Stefan, du hast einen Knall. Das ist auf jeden Fall keine Ahnung. Wir reden über den Staircase-Killer, wo es die absurde, bizarre Theorie gibt, dass eine Eule einen Menschen ermordet hat. Und ich bin immer noch der Meinung, dass das wahrscheinlich korrekt ist. Inzwischen wurden auch sogar Federn im Haar gefunden. Also es ist eine lächerlich gut begründete We're the Fan-Theorie und ich kann dazu nur die HBO-Serie empfehlen. Der Name ist mir entfallen, ich glaube, es ist auch einfach The Staircase. Ja, und du kannst dir nicht vorstellen, dass jemand kurz bevor er stirbt sich Federschmuck in den Kopf steckt und dann stirbt. Es war kein Federschmuck, es waren die Federn einer örtlich ansässigen Eule, die Kratzspuren deuten auch darauf hin. hin. Ich denke mir oft, eigentlich bin ich gesund, weil ich lebe in einer so dreckigen und unvorzeigbaren Wohnung, dass ich unmöglich damit rechnen kann, zu sterben. Weil, also hätte ich wirklich Angst, ich denke mir so, habe ich gerade Todesangst? Frage ich mich manchmal. Ich glaube, wenn du diese Frage stellst, hast du sie nicht. Und denk mir, nee, eigentlich nicht. Nee. Weil sonst würde ich meine Wohnung aufräumen. Oder schreien, oder was macht man? Fliehen oder irgendwie um Hilfe rufen, ja? Nein, nichts davon ist der Fall. Aber ich denke mir, nee, ich denke jetzt nicht, dass ich im Schlaf einfach sterbe, weil meine Wohnung ist so unaufgeräumt und so unpräsentabel, dass ich glaube so, je näher du dem Ende kommst, desto mehr musst du in Ordnung leben eigentlich, oder? Weil irgendwann kommt die Feuerwehr und bricht deine Tür auf oder irgendwie sowas. Und eigentlich ist es ziemlich deprimierend, dass du im Alter dann noch so ordentlich sein musst, dass du dich da nicht richtig gehen lassen kannst, oder? Also als Alter für dich gleich verknüpft mit ordnungsliebend? Naja, wenn man denkt, oh, also man hört ja dann, okay, stirbt und nur die Katze ist in der Wohnung und dann kommt die Polizei und dann kann ja nicht irgendwie dann der Abfluss kaputt sein und du hast eine Plastikkiste unterm Waschbecken stehen. Und die Pfandflaschen, die vielen, vielen Pfandflaschen. Die tausenden Pfandflaschen. Du willst ja niemandem zu Last fallen, ja, ja. Ja. Aber was sagt das über mich aus, dass ich jemand, der eigentlich ein bisschen ordnungsliebend ist? Vielleicht hast du, vielleicht ist es eine Auswirkung, Ausprägung von Todesangst. Ach so, Angst, ja. Todesangst oder Todestrieb, dass du denkst, okay, du willst dich selbst vernichten und willst ein schönes Bild hinterlassen. Hast du da mal drüber nachgedacht, Stefan? Ich habe das Gefühl, du denkst da kaum drüber nach. Puh, ich finde es eigentlich eine schöne Eigenschaft und ich glaube, das kann man noch positiv bewerten und dass du jetzt so, dass mal wieder Todes... Warum kreuzt du gerade die Finger? Dass mal wieder Todessehnsucht deine Diagnose ist, macht mir ein bisschen Angst, aber ja, vielleichtnung, Unordnung verbreiten, weil meinst du, dann springt man dem Tod eher von der Schippe?
Ich glaube schon, ich glaube, du reisst dich mehr zusammen.
Angenommen, ich werde entführt, ich würde alles geben, um da wieder rauszukommen.
Und nicht, weil ich meine Freiheit zu Liebe sage, ja, ja, ja, ja, ich würde wirklich, ja, ich will jetzt realistisch bleiben, sagen wir mal gute 70 Prozent, was für mich das wirklich viel ist. Aber ich würde wirklich sagen, nee, das Letzte, was ich jetzt brauchen kann, ist Polizei in meiner Wohnung, Spurensuche, meine Eltern in meiner Wohnung und wo könnte er sein? Was machen wir mit ihm? Wir können ihn nicht hinführen. Er gibt 70 Prozent, merkst du, was er gibt? Er hält sich fest, er hält sich am Geländer fest. Zirk, fest da, oh, zirk, oh!
Ich krieg ihn nicht vom Geländer.
Wir können ihn nicht, ich versteh nicht, dein Bayerisch.
Wir können ihn nicht verstehen.
Aber ich, nee, sorry, aber jetzt machen alle Entführer da draußen keine fucking Chance.
Ihr kriegt mich nicht, ihr kriegt mich wirklich nicht.
Ich sag auch von mir aus, pass auf, pass auf, okay? Ihr könnt mich entführen. Gebt mir eine Stunde. Ich gehe in meine Wohnung, ich räume auf. Ich vernichte Spuren für euch. Ich vernichte falsche Spuren für euch. Kein Problem, wir drucken so einen Tick nach Panama aus. Du hast eh das Potenzial, dass du so wahnsinnig verrückt wirkst, dass man dich gar nicht dass man eher Angst hat vor dir und dich nicht entführen will. Aber was ich zusammenbekomme, weil du willst das ja so, du magst das ja so. Im Dreck wohnen, ja. Im Dreck wohnen, sich im Dreck zuhlen. Richtig. Und das verstehe ich auch. So unhygienisch wie möglich, genau. Das macht mir Spaß. Das macht dir Spaß, das bist du, das ist deine Persönlichkeit. Ja, korrekt. Und jetzt frage ich mich halt, du problematisierst das ja aber auch, weil du sagst, naja, so eine Wohnung, die würdest du jetzt ungern vorzeigen in einem Entführungsfalle.
Und jetzt frage ich mich, warum, wie kriegst du das denn zusammen? Wie kannst du mit diesem Widerspruch leben, dass du sowohl darum weißt, dass es nicht der Norm entspricht und dich sogar ein bisschen dafür schämst, auf der anderen Seite ist es aber genau das, wie du leben willst. Sei doch stolz, zeig doch den Entführern stolz deine Wohnung. Nee, ich glaube, das ist auch ein Zeichen von Unabhängigkeit. Wenn immer deine Eltern gesagt haben, räum dein Zimmer auf, sagst du, nee, ich bin jetzt alleine, ich habe ein ganz dreckiges Zimmer, ganz bewusst, und ihr könnt mir nichts anhaben, und ich mache, was ich will, und ihr könnt nichts dazu haben, bis ich entführt werde, und dann leider, dann müsst ihr rein. Na, räumt doch ihr auch heute euer Zimmer auf, oder morgen, oder übermorgen, oder macht es nicht. Seidlich Florentin, er hätte auch was zu was gefragt. Vielleicht habt ihr gerade das Zimmer aufgeräumt, hören wir oft Leute, hören den Podcast, während sie das Zimmer aufräumen, also jetzt fühlt ihr euch besser, jetzt habt ihr ein bisschen Ordnung reingebracht und ja, wir hören uns dann nächste Woche wieder, ich würde mich freuen. Wir hören mal rein, ich freue mich auch. Ich würde mich freuen, wenn ihr nochmal vorbeischaut, also ich hätte Lust auf eine weitere Folge. Ja, ich hätte auch Bock auf eine weitere Folge, hätte ich auch noch Bock. Ja, aber also, ihr da guckt dann aber einfach weiter.
Aber ja, haut rein und wir wünschen euch eine ganz, ganz schöne Woche.
Macht's gut und wir hieben ab.